dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with carriage a knife here image
and color editing is an actively
research topic with really cool
applications that you will see in a
second most of the existing solutions
are either easy to use but lacking
expressiveness or they are expressive
but too complex for novices to use
computation time is also an issue as
some of the operations in Photoshop can
take more than a minute to carry out for
color editing the workflow is very
simple the program extracts the dominant
colors of an image which we can
interactively edit ourselves an example
use case would be recovering the girls
blue sweater tu turquoise or changing
the overall tone of the image to orange
existing tools that can do this are
usually either too slow or only
accessible to adapt users it is also
important to note that it is quite easy
to take these great results for granted
using a naive color transfer technique
will destroy a sizable part of the
dynamic range of the image and hence
legitimate features which are all
preserved if we use this algorithm
instead
one can also use masks to selectively
edit different parts of the image the
technique execute really quickly opening
up the possibility of not real time but
interactive recoloring of animated
sequences or
also leverage the efficiency of the
method to edit not one but a collection
of images in one go
the paper also contains a rigorous
evaluation against existing techniques
for instance they show that this method
executed 3 2 20 times faster than the
one implemented in adobe photoshop
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time